You know, we usually like
to start the show
with something fun
and high-energy
to make the audience go "Whoo!"
ALL:
Whoo!
Not yet.
Today, I wanted to mix things up
and talk about a serious issue
relating to November's election.
On the ballot this year,
Californians will participate
in an historic vote to finally
legalize recreational marijuana.
(cheers and applause)
Why is it that people "whoo"
at the word "marijuana,"
but if I just gave you
marijuana,
you'd be like, "Sweet."?
-(laughter) -They're finally
making it easier
to get pot in California
by cutting out that arduous step
of going to a fake doctor
in a strip mall
and lying about headaches.
There's clearly a lot
of excitement about this.
In fact,
Matthew McConaughey's been
sleeping outside
his polling place right there.
-(laughter)
-That's definitely him.
Now, comedians,
I do not partake in the weed.
I'm a sober fellow,
but I don't hold it
against you if you enjoy it.
Let's attempt to pander
to the audience
in the opposite direction,
all right? What we need is
a slogan that anti-marijuana
lobbyists will use
in the upcoming election.
Let's take the other side.
-Jim Jefferies, go.
-Vote!
We dare you, because voting
requires you
to show up somewhere
at an exact date.
HARDWICK:
Yes! All right, perfect.
(cheers and applause)
Perfect.
Nikki Glaser.
Aren't the lines
at Taco Bell long enough?
Yeah. Points.
-(applause and cheering)
-I'll see you down there.
Brett Gellman.
Why have a joint in your pocket
when you can have a gun
in your hand?